el tema muy concreto nosotros tenemos
tres años de un esquema este esquema ha
sufrido una cantidad de circunstancias
que han cambiado a su alrededor el
planteamiento que estamos haciendo es
que tenemos que revisar a fondo cómo
está organizada la alternativa
democrática en venezuela la oposición en
venezuela porque no podemos quedarnos
pegados en el mismo esquema y lo que
estamos haciendo es una consideración
radical de que tenemos que crear un
nuevo espacio de unidad sociedad civil
partido político venezuela entera para
volver a reconstruir una presión interna
que se ha perdido y también una atención
internacional que se ha perdido de
manera que eso para nosotros después de
tres años es más que lógico con todos
los problemas escándalos que ha habido
que se plantee la necesidad de rediseñar
relanzar repensar cómo está organizada
el día de hoy la alternativa democrática
en venezuela también nos dijo que falta
para que haya unidad dentro de la
oposición si es cuestión de encontrar un
nuevo líder o si lo que los divide son
las diferentes ideas y valores entre los
integrantes
esto yo yo creo que se trata de que
estos son ciclos lamentablemente
nosotros logramos mucho hemos tenido la
mayoría de las veces una unidad muy
fuerte pero en este momento estamos como
una especie encrucijada de repensar de
agotamiento y no se trata de un tema de
personas que sirve liderazgos personales
o individuales yo creo que más bien se
trata de unir a todo lo que es el
espectro de partidos políticos y
sociedad civil bajo un mismo horizonte
vamos a un mismo plan de trabajo bajo
una misma estrategia y eso que suenan
tan obvio hoy no lo tenemos y allí el
drama el llamado dramático que hemos
hecho hoy primero de que quedan menos de
un mes para crear ese nuevo reglamento
legal si no todo desaparece y en segundo
lugar que tenemos que repensar todo para
poder reconstruir y relanzar la unidad
democrática en venezuela
borges nos contó además sobre sus planes
ahora que sale del gobierno interino y
sí sí y si consideraría lanzarse como
esa figura que una a la oposición en
venezuela
no es que yo creo que lo que hay que
hacer es más bien
dejar de pensar que un líder o una
persona o una figura fuerte es la que
tiene que unir a venezuela obviamente
siempre se necesita liderazgos
personales pero lo que no tenemos que
tener a diferencia de los liderazgos
personalistas esa visión de mis tías yo
creo que nosotros tenemos a bien unida
que en este aumento unir al país
nacional venezolano que me refiero la
iglesia los estudiantes universitarios
el empresariado los venezolanos afuera
los partidos políticos la sociedad civil
todo eso ahorita está muy a la deriva y
el llamado que estamos haciendo es que
hay que reunir de nuevo como una ruta
con una visión y con una estrategia no
lo tenemos tenemos que sacudirnos de la
manera como estamos ahora paralizados y
más bien abrir un debate constructivo y
plantear eso una ruta un equipo y un
liderazgo